and so
once i found these things out and i
started to put get these these nutrients
because a foundational question and and
this answer for everybody
is if you are experiencing damage to a
particular tissue
a simple question is what is a tissue
made of right what is it made of because
you have to supply your body with the
raw materials to build that thing
and our bodies are amazing they can do a
patchwork job on you
but once you give your body the ideal
things your body's so intelligent it
will suit it will preferentially choose
the right stuff and so i start to flood
my body initially i became a natural
pill popper to be honest like i was like
oh this nutri very expensive on a
college budget and also not sustainable
it wasn't that it's lacking in
intelligence a layer of intelligence
there with these synthetic isolated
nutrients versus the real foods that
they're found in with all these
biopotentiators and all these other
nutrients
that in my nutritional science class i
was not taught about that stuff i was
taught to tell patients make sure you
get plenty of vitamin c what kind
there's multiple forms of vitamin c
there's multiple forms of vitamins don't
you just love that vitamin c is
supposedly the hot like everybody thinks
oh orange juice but it's higher in like
kiwis and strawberries and
other things like that are you know
seemingly
you know that are more healthy than
drinking a glass of orange juice
that's because of marketing you know
this you know marketing was telling us
get your drink your oga your get your
sunny d
barely is really orange juice
that i don't even know what i don't even
till this day and it's tang do you ever
remember tang i love of course when i
was a kid i had that bang
in the commercials it was i think it was
like some lips it was just like some
lips with the legs and it's just like
yeah but i mean the ingredients on there
are in pure insanity you know some of
the stuff has actually been a couple of
ingredients in tang are not no longer in
use because they've been banned
but so i what i did was i shifted to to
the to the real foods and just start to
flood my body with these nutrients
and the third thing was
if you're not sleeping well you're not
healing well yeah my biggest struggle
over those two years was sleeping at
night i was in so much pain and the
things that i was doing during the day
ended up helping me to sleep better at
night and once i could start to sleep
and i'm providing my body with these
building these very essential critical
building blocks
and the movement because i came across a
study
it was actually on race horses
and this is a multi-billion dollar
uh
entity as well
and racehorse might be worth tens of
millions of dollars if they break a leg
that can be a major thing so they did
this study and they find out how between
the horse and their sperm they're worth
a lot
right
it's a very i mean shout out to you
every guy in the world is like man i
want a stud feet
shout out to the what is it called the
the the what is the derby the triple
crown shout out to the triple crown but
you know they want to increase the bone
density of these horses so they had a
control group and then they had a a
study group where they gave the horses
basically what i was doing
supplementation increased nutrition to
increase their bone density and it did
improve their bone density but they had
another study group of horses that they
gave nutri nutrition to and walked the
horses and they had an even higher
increase in their bone density and this
speaks to what movement is really for
unfortunately we've d we've devolved
from an understanding of what movement
is about which this concept of going and
exercising which i love
is a new invention we never had that as
a
as a species throughout our evolution
because movement was just life we just
lifted heavy stuff we we moved around we
had plenty of of walking and foraging
and all these different things now
that's true like you were just a farmer
you built things or you know there was
no it wasn't like you'd purposely walk
into a box
where there was like bars hanging and
things on the wall to throw and
dumbbells and yeah that's totally true
never thought about that
yeah it's so interesting because and
this leads into
what does this mean for us what did that
movement that our genes expect us to
move our dna
expects us to move is a part of being
human
and so what this movement is if you
think about the word exercise it's very
close to the word exorcise
by the way which kind of means to expel
things to get things out of the
environment and a big part of exercise
that we have now mountains of period
evidence on
is elimination right this quote
detoxification
uh supporting mechanisms through
exercise and through movement but
another big part of exercise is
assimilation
and being able to actually absorb all
the the good stuff that you're eating if
you're changing your nutrition you're
not getting the full benefit unless
you're moving your body that's what
exercise is really about assimilation
digestion and also elimination such a
powerful supportive force in those
things so bottom line um
about
two weeks
from that day of making that decision i
was already feeling incredibly better
but it was six weeks later that i
realized that the pain i've been
experiencing every day in my life for
those two years that had me terrified it
was gone now i wanna i wanna make this
clear
i was so afraid that it would come back
i was just i was actually terrified
because it's just like what is what if i
make a wrong step i don't know what
happened i was look i was so used to
having the pain i was looking for the
pain it was
exciting neuroplasticity was
you know had happened and needs to
happen again you learned how to
you learned how to be worried about pain
and now you have to learn how to not
worry about it
exactly that is exactly right and
during that period people start to come
up to me at the university that i worked
at i mean i didn't work there yet that i
was going to school at and
teachers so professors would come up to
me
and fellow students faculty members
these just started to be like it was
like a magnetic thing they was coming up
and they were like what did you do you
look so healthy like like it was a
problem because i looked i looked like a
complete ghost are you on drugs and
you're like actually i'm off of them
so they're coming up and asking me
and then they would ask me if i can help
them and so these start to become like
the first clients that i was working
with as i was working on my degree
and i got a scan on my uh spine done
about it took it was nine months later
and i was still i was scared
i didn't need to get that affirmation
but i kind of did i want to see for
myself and i saw the last position
that i'd worked with and he put the mri
out for me and my my two herniated discs
l4 and l5 s1 they had retracted on their
own and my degeneration
had reversed essentially and i could see
the light shining through my disc again
they look like healthy
discs
whereas you know my first physician said
that the spine of an eight-year-old and
now here i was and you know at the time
he was he asked me what i did
and i told him like you know
at the time at the time i didn't have
the vocabulary and i was so
overjoyed with this experience
that and everybody out there who's who
knows about health is passionate about
health they probably have this
experience that you just start saying
all this stuff and people just don't
they're not even getting it's so over
the head i'm like i'm i'm exercising and
i'm i've
do you know about you know this quote
superfoods and all these different in it
he's just like okay yeah yeah but he's
like whatever you're doing keep doing it
instead of really he's seeing the my mri
instead of him really inquiring
what did you do
to get these results so i can replicate
this in other patients
that's what he said to me and i left
there he asked you he didn't ask you or
he did yeah he did but it was just kind
of like a formality he wasn't he didn't
really the answer that i gave him didn't
fit the paradigm that he was expecting
like i guess they thought maybe i took
some experimental new drug i don't know
but i didn't give him the answer that he
wanted and uh this is the the cherry on
top of story from that moment you know i
was already working with people but i
you know graduated got my degree i was
already a strength conditioning coach
uh at that point i really went intense
in that i shifted all my coursework back
to biology and kinesiology nutritional
science opened my clinical practice as a
nutritionist worked with thousands of
people in a one-on-one context and also
just small workshops and things like
that and saw you know i've got people
coming in
400 their blood sugar is like 400 you
know they're on metformin insulin people
on you know the centerpro for heart
disease and hypertension and you know
folks who are diagnosed with cancer and
all these different things and seeing so
much success a lot of those stories
where people who they they've been told
the same thing there's nothing you can
do about this
and the number one thing that i would do
and so for example we had about an 80
uh success rate with folks coming in who
were diagnosed with type 2 diabetes to
normalize their blood sugar without
medication working with their along with
their physician
oftentimes within a matter of weeks you
know and what the number one thing that
we did i literally would just
take the time i would a lot the time
to sit down with them i had this this
board you know this white board and i
would walk them through kind of reverse
engineer the disease like okay so you're
diagnosed with diabetes here's how it
works
here's your pancreas these are alpha
cells these are beta cells and i would
take them through the process
and i could see the light come on in
their eyes like they're literally like
waking up in that moment like i had no
idea what was happening in my own body